ça va nous faire beaucoup de bien ce
petit week-end
c'est pourtant s'amarrer à partager ses
secrets les plus intimes
pour le meilleur et pour le pire tu
viens moi se mettre à l'aise
pareil tu crois que ton mari va
débarquer d'une minute à l'autre
c'est à la personne a même abouti tu
seras pas mort non arrête j'aime pas ça
je suis sérieuse baisse marquée au
second garde il faut tout ça pour être
excité puisqu'on a retrouvé arriver là
les bruits c'est vrai non
oh
et toi allez réveille-toi c'est l'heure
de se lever mon cher
cinq heures que tu a gâché rue en
hurlant pour prévenir des voisins qui
habitent à 800 mètres si jamais sont
encore là ce que tu sais combien de
temps plus long sans eau
ça marchera pas oublie ça tu peux tirer
jusqu'à te faire péter le poignet temps
et devra passer maintenant mais de paris
petit bébé ne dit pas moi concentre toi
toi et moi on s'est tué samedi bull
depuis que tu as 12 ans elle est très
jolie robe
il t'a mis ses menottes aux poignets
bien avant que gérard mal face ça va ma
souris tu peux trouver autour de toi
tout ce dont tu as besoin pour survivre
il te suffit de souligner à
recul ça suffit si tu ne te réveilles tu
vas crever
[Musique]